Iran's president says his country will
not surrender or negotiate with the US
under pressure he spoke as the u.s.
revealed more evidence claiming that it
shows Iran is buying recent attacks on
oil tankers in the Middle East Charlie
d'Agata is in the United Arab Emirates
where he was shown that evidence from
the US military just a few hours ago
good morning well we just wrapped up a
briefing with Navy investigators here in
the United Arab Emirates we were shown
fragments from one of the exploded
weapons also crucially a magnet that was
allegedly left behind from whoever
planted these limpet mines now the
information that we received this
morning is meant to stack up the case
against Iran but at this point all they
would confirm is that these limpet mines
bear a striking resemblance to those
used by Iran in other words we don't
have the smoking gun they cannot say
definitively that the limpet mines used
in these attacks these are prolific
weapons and can be found in many places
were actually made inside Iran now all
of this evidence was literally laid out
and explained to us by investigators the
top investigators for the US Navy pit
fleet at a briefing here this morning
we're told there will be more details in
the days ahead for CBS this morning
Charlie d'Agata in Fujairah the United
Arab Emirates